barry weiss on her sub stack has a
report written by
katie herzog that's uh it's really a
must read and it's about
the infiltration of gender theory into
medical school
um so here's uh
here's a little bit of it so it says
during a recent
endocrinology course at a top medical
school in the university of california
system
a professor stopped mid-lecture to
apologize for something he'd said at the
beginning of the class
quote i don't want you to think that i'm
in any way trying to imply anything
and if you can summon some generosity
forgive me i would really appreciate it
the physician says in a recording
provided by a student in the class
who will call lauren again i'm very
sorry for that
it was it was certainly not my intention
to offend anyone
the worst thing that i could do as a
human being is be offensive
his offense using the term pregnant
woman
okay this is in medical school
we're gonna go right past the statement
the worst thing i can do as a human
being
is be offensive how how revealing is
that
someone who believes that the worst
thing you can do
it's not murder it's not rape the worst
thing
it's not it's not pedophilia no the
worst thing is to offend someone with
your words
and he really believes that
quote i said when a woman is pregnant
which implies that only women can get
pregnant
and i most sincerely apologize to all of
you
it wasn't the first time that lauren had
heard an instructor apologize for using
language that to most americans
would seem utterly inoffensive words
like male and female
why would medical school professors
apologize for referring to a patient's
biological sex because
lauren explains in the context of her
medical school
acknowledging biological sex can be
considered transphobic
when sex is acknowledged by instructors
it's sometimes portrayed as a social
construct
not a biological reality
in a lecture on transgender health an
instructor declared
biological sex sexual orientation and
gender are all constructs
these are all constructs that we have
created
i can't really it's worth going uh to
barry weiss's substance finding that and
reading the whole report
it is this is bone chilling stuff not
surprising
we knew it was going to get to this
gender theory had
made its inroads into grade school
um you know into undergraduate courses
and
it was only a matter of time before it
would fully
intrude into medical school
of course the problem is a pretty
significant one is that you you
cannot do medicine if you don't
recognize biological reality that is the
foundation of medicine is human biology
and understanding human biology you you
cannot be a doctor who doesn't
understand human biology
because this is what you're working with
this is what you're trying to treat
so if you don't understand it or are not
going to allow yourself
to acknowledge it then medicine ceases
to exist
we also know that this was this was
inevitable this uh
we were always going to get to this
point you know
once we allowed this artificial
bifurcation of
sex and gender
gender up until the 1950s and 1960s
nobody talked about human beings having
a gender there was no need for the term
there still is no need for it
we don't need to talk about that you
have a sex and that's what you have
there's no need for to go any further
than that
and we have the words masculinity and
femininity to talk about
the way that uh that that men and women
typically act and the way that they
interact with the world so we already
have those terms
and if you had a man who acts in a more
feminine way then you could just say
that you don't need to talk about well
his gender
he's his sex is male but his gender is
female because he acts in a feminine way
adding this extra label into it only
confuses matters by
intentionally but the gender theory
proponents the gender theory cultists
really
for decades after introducing after
taking gender from the realm of
of language which is where it had been
before words had gender
okay obviously you can't talk about a
word having a biological sex but a word
can have
gender gendered language which is now
offensive
so he took that out of the realm of
language started applying it to people
and for decades we were told
that's two different things you have
your biological sex and you have your
gender
um lots of people went along with that
that became a kind of this this
mainstream understanding that people had
even though it really didn't make any
sense
and now what we're watching over the
last couple of years and it is a very
significant development
and it was also entirely inevitable it's
always going to go this way
we're watching that distinction once
again collapse
now it's just it's the same thing sex
and gender once again are the same thing
except that now really when we talk
about the distinction being collapsed
we've just erased biological sex and now
there is only gender
and you can use sex to refer to gender
but that's all that really is that all
there is is the human construct
something to keep in mind uh you know
going forward when you go to the doctor
you might want to do a quick quiz just
before deciding who your primary care
physician is going to be
this might be an important thing to do
uh you know they'll they'll do a checkup
with you they'll do a kind of a
preliminary physical
well you might want to do a preliminary
checkup with them
and ask them a few questions like hey
hey doc by the way can
can a man get pregnant if they say yes
to that if they say
anything but no go find another doctor
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated